bueno suba ha secundado a ven durante la
gran parte de este último periodo en el
poder era la apuesta más previsible por
parte del partido oficialista para
suceder a agraviar dos ministros más que
sacaron algunos votos pero que quedaron
muy lejos y la verdad que era visto
tanto por el establishment político como
económico como la persona capaz de
garantizar la continuidad de las
políticas sobre todo económicas de ave
pero también de política exterior que
habían sido muy valoradas por el
electorado japonés en este último tiempo
por supuesto que la pandemia trastocó
todo esto y ahora el principal desafío
de suva es tratar de hacer resurgir a
japón en el medio de una crisis
económica que no tiene precedentes del
fin de la segunda guerra señor que justo
ya usted lo dice es un tema importante
son las relaciones internacionales
principalmente con la unión europea y
eeuu que son los grandes aliados de
japón pero su gun no es una ficha que
tenga mucho fogueo digámoslo así en la
escena internacional qué podemos esperar
entonces en materia internacional d
la posible llegada de sugar al puesto de
primer ministro en japón este es un
punto muy importante uno de los quizás
de los defectos de subas que no es un
personaje carismático es un burócrata
con una muy buena formación mucha
experiencia en gestión pero no tiene
roce internacional ni tampoco el
contacto diario con la gente cercano que
tenía el saliente ave entonces en
política exterior se le vienen desafíos
importantísimos se le ha dicho que va a
privilegiar la alianza estrategia que
con los eeuu ave tuvo problemas
equilibrando con una administración de
donald trump con la que ha tenido muchos
problemas y también tenemos relaciones
muy tensas con corea del sur y con china
donde hay una gran interdependencia
económica pero por el tema de disputas
territoriales y cuestiones de seguridad
la situación ha estado calando en las
últimas semanas con lo cual lo que
quiero decir es que suba va a tener que
probarse como diplomático una función
que hasta ahora él no venía desempeñando
todo un reto en materia internacional
señor justo
retos tendrá al interior de japón porque
el escenario político es complicado
ahora para la mayoría de los mandatarios
a nivel internacional por el contexto de
la pandemia del cobi 19 como es el japón
que va a recibir su gas y es elegido
como primer ministro está recibiendo un
campeón que ya venía en recesión previo
a la pandemia y la pandemia de alguna
forma la profundizado japón
probablemente caiga más de seis puntos
no supere y este año con proyecciones de
algún rebote para 2021 pero cuidado todo
va a tener que ver con el manejo de la
pandemia en un primer momento japón fue
elogiado por cómo gestionó la pandemia
de kobe pero está viendo rebrotes en
toques en otras importantes ciudades
sembrando nuevamente dudas de si se
hicieron bien o mal las aperturas así
que suba también se va a tener que
probar como un líder en el medio de esta
crisis no solamente económica sino
también sanitaria y además en los
políticos de completo dentro de un año
probablemente va a haber elecciones hay
un rumor de que se podrían adelantar las
elecciones pero con esto de la pandemia
probablemente no suceda
y otros contendientes probablemente que
van a querer disputar ese lugar del
primer ministro hacia el 2021 señor
patricio visto el director del
observatorio sino argentino desde la
ciudad de mar del plata muchas gracias
por este análisis para france24